das sind wirklich gute nachrichten nach
dem wochenende bei dem vermutet wurde
dass weniger positive tests auf saas
kopf 2 gemeldet werden konnten hat sich
der trend der letzten woche aber weiter
und noch deutlicher fortgesetzt das
können wir mit unserer datenanalyse
zeigen allerdings reicht das noch lange
nicht denn das ziel ist ein anderes
klicks um science-fiction gibt es jetzt
auch als podcast der link dazu ist unten
in der video beschreibung los geht's
herzlich willkommen die zahlen des
letzten wochenendes waren mit gesunder
skepsis zu betrachten das
robert-koch-institut vermutete einfach
weniger meldungen da weniger fälle eben
gemeldet würden doch schon in der woche
davor zeigte sich eine leicht positive
entwicklung dazu muss man allerdings
sagen dass gerade die werte am anfang
der woche noch sehr ungenau waren weil
da die fallzahlen noch niedrig waren mit
7272 am montag und einer steigerung vom
vortag von 25,1 prozent und 1459 in den
tagen danach aber stiegen die fallzahlen
allerdings deutlich mit täglichen
steigerungsraten von im schnitt 30
prozent das heißt jeden tag stiegen die
zahlen um rund 30 prozent mehr ein
exponentielles wachstum schon damals
sanken aber die steigerungsraten leicht
aber bei diesen geringen zahlen sind
diese werte nur begrenzt aussagefähig
jetzt allerdings bei höheren fallzahlen
und auch einer zahlenmäßig immer
größeren steigerung ist dieser trend
erstens viel aussagekräftiger und
zweitens er setzt sich fort nachdem es
also in der vorherigen woche erraten um
die 30 prozent waren sind es jetzt und
das eben nicht nur am wochenende von
gestern 16,8 prozent das heißt selbst
wenn jetzt fälle nachgemeldet worden
sind ist die steigerungsrate nicht
deutlich gestiegen wie es erwartet
worden war
und das sind gute nachrichten das robert
koch institut ist hier noch
zurückhaltend allerdings sieht es auch
diese positive entwicklung
und ja der trend ist auch beständig und
deutlich was sehr dafür spricht dass die
zahlen stimmen natürlich ist es immer
noch möglich dass daten nicht
übermittelt worden oder tests in baden
württemberg unter den tisch gefallen
sind allerdings ist das in einer so
ernsthaften situation nicht in hohem
maße zu erwarten und trotzdem ist das
gerade mal ein etappenziel die
steigerungsrate
muss auf null gedrückt werden sprich
statt einer exponentiellen funktion muss
die kurve linear werden es gibt da nicht
jeden tag mehr neu infizierte sondern
dieser wert muss stabil bleiben und die
grenze liegt hier bei 40.000 infizierten
pro tag bei der annahme dass fünf
prozent davon auf die intensivstation
müssen und dort etwa zehn tage bleiben
liegt die zahl der schweren
krankheitsverläufe darüber oder müssen
sie länger auf der intensivstation
bleiben muss diese zahl niedriger sein
das hat harald lesch ja sehr gut
vorgerechnet dabei gehen wir von 20.000
intensivbetten aus die wir jetzt frei
haben müssten
da gibt es keine zahlen das ist eine
annahme also drei dinge erstens die
maßnahmen vor zwei wochen
veranstaltungen absagen geisterspiele
haben bereits gegriffen
zweitens sie haben aber nicht
ausgereicht weil drittens die
steigerungsrate auf null sinken muss
denn nur wenn die kurve linear wird
haben wir überhaupt eine chance aber wie
geht es dann weiter studie corona virus
soll gezielt verbreitet werden anklicken
anschauen und klicks um science-fiction
unbedingt abonnieren nur dann bleibt ihr
auf dem laufenden bis dann bleibt dran